Speaker 1: Here's a little interesting video.
This the video I'm about to play for you is of
radical Republican Congressman Matt Gaetz. And
he was. Very mildly, confronted about the fact
that he continues to insist that Trump won on
local TV and this is being reported sort of all
over the place. As Matt Gates gets humiliating
reality, check to his face on live local TV or
on AlterNet Matt Gates slapped with epic reality
check after echoing Trump's voter fraud claims.
It's not really what happened now. I
appreciate. I appreciate that Gates was pushed,
you know, challenged at all on his
lies about 2020. But basically,
what happens here is Gates says, I believe
Trump won, and the interviewer goes, Yeah, but
that would require like a lot of conspiracy,
you know, a lot of people acting together.
And then Gates just spews a ton of
nonsense. So it's not it's not a major
reality check. Let's take a look at it.
Speaker 5: So you're still maintaining
2020 election was stolen. We're still going with
that. Listen, I believe that Donald Trump won
the 2020 election. I believe that he won the
election. You can't. We can't say that without
saying that there was a gigantic conspiracy
across this country. And Supervisor of Elections
Office is everywhere right to make this happen.
And we haven't still seen any evidence that
proves that yet, because so many of the courts
that should have taken those matters up rejected
evidentiary hearings on jurisdiction grounds.
I mean, I know the affidavits that came out
of Michigan regarding the TCF Center in Detroit.
Speaker 1: Now remember, this brings us back to.
Affidavits are not evidence, and yes, affidavits
affidavits can can be introduced and examined,
but affidavits are not actually evidence, and
this is just another one of the lines that they
keep repeating. It's almost taking me back to
December of 2020 after we but we have affidavit
affidavits are not strictly speaking evidence
Speaker 5: established a factual basis to be
able to go and have evidentiary hearings. But
too often I think judges just didn't have the
courage to take it up. It's most unfortunate,
but I'm still engaged in the fight and election
integrity going forward. Oh yeah, because Florida
used to be the laughing stock of elections and
governor, two Santas fired the elections officials
who didn't run clean elections. And now, lo and
behold, Florida is a model for the country, so
I want to bring Florida's message and our story.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine Florida as a model
for the country? So listen, I mean, like, it's
great that he was asked, Where's your evidence for
that? But at the same time, that was not exactly
a brutal reality check that it's made out to be.
Now, notice the language Matt Gates uses, he says.
I believe Donald Trump won. They are the ones
who always say facts don't care about your
feelings. And yet he believes Trump won absent
any actual facts that would point that way.
One other thing there is this whole. So Matt Gaetz
has a lot going on. One of the things is he's
being investigated for the potential child sex
trafficking and all of that he's hired a child,
you know, sex crime defense attorney and all
of these different things. On the other hand,
he's also palling around with Marjorie Taylor
Greene and telling lies about the election. The
third thing is, there's still this very strange
story about how he says his dad was extorted by
someone or there was an attempt to extort. He's
also asked about that during this interview.
Speaker 5: Any updates on the
Department of Justice investigation
into the one big update is that since we talked
last, the individual who had been indicted for
trying to extort me pled guilty to extorting me
and my family. And I hope that that applies to
the Wire Fraud Trust, and I hope that that
investigation is ongoing because other people
literally went on national television and said
they were working with Steve Alford in this deal.
Those people should be the next to be indicted.
Speaker 1: OK, so he hopes. But I but I guess
since though, if the investigation is still going
on, it would be really great for one of these
cartoonish Trumpian right wingers to have a really
big fall from grace. And we've talked before about
fishy stuff with Marjorie Taylor Greene and
taking to homestead exemptions, which you
can only take one. And I'm not going to go back
through what a homestead declaration of homestead
is and all of that, but you're only allowed to
have one that was being investigated, you know,
that had fallen to some kind of investigative
black hole, we don't know. Lauren Boebert, a whole
bunch of different campaign funds related things.
Will anything ever come of it? We don't know.
Madison Cawthorn, whole other thing. You know,
the Russian honeypot. I mean, we can't even get
into that right now. Matt Gates, the one facing
the most serious criminal charges. Potentially,
it would be a really interesting thing to see
if one of these, you know, the major cartoonist
Trump is the younger cartoonist, Trumpists. Are
people like these, not cartoonists. This guys know
this. Guys know Bill Watterson, that's for sure.
But the most cartoonish Trumpist are Boebert,
Gates, Greene and Cawthorn. At this point, sort
of. If one of them had a real big fall from grace,
particularly if they had criminal charges
against them or some other major scandal,
it would be interesting to see how Trump would
react in general to that group, probably initially
saying they're being railroaded. But over the
long term, maybe he would sort of step back from
supporting that group. Unclear. We will see we
will follow it. But hey, at least they asked Matt
Gates to try to defend the claim that Trump won in
November. He didn't do a great job, but he tried